Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je m'appelle Héloïse Martin.
Pour ceux qui ne me connaissent pas,
c’est-à-dire à peu près tout le monde,
je vous propose de faire
une petite recherche Google.
[Héloïse Martin... poids]
Je vous l’accorde, sur Google,
ça ne saute pas aux yeux,
mais je suis comédienne.
J’ai fait des films au cinéma, des séries,
du théâtre, des émissions de télé.
Mais apparemment, mon poids est le sujet
de recherche numéro un
quand on tape mon nom sur Internet.
C'est marrant, ça.
Enfin, non, pas tellement.
C’est même très étrange de vouloir
connaître mon poids, ma taille,
mes mensurations.
C’est vrai, qu’est-ce que ça change ?
Quand on rencontre quelqu’un,
lui demande-t-on son poids ?
Ben non, on lui demande
ce qu’il fait dans la vie,
s’il a des passions, s’il a des enfants.
Eh bien, moi, je suis bretonne,
passionnée par le cinéma.
J’adore faire la cuisine, j’adore danser,
j’adore faire du basket.
Et pourtant, la plupart des recherches
concernent mon physique.
Si ça s’arrêtait là,
ce ne serait pas vraiment dramatique.
Connaissez-vous le point commun
entre la Grèce antique,
l’époque de la Renaissance italienne,
l’époque victorienne en Angleterre,
ou bien l’âge d’or hollywoodien ?
Eh bien, à ces différentes époques,
le standard de beauté
était la femme ronde,
potelée, au ventre arrondi
et aux hanches larges.
Donc, en fait, je suis un standard
de beauté qui n’est pas né au bon siècle.
Génial !
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, mon corps dérange.
Ce n’est pas une question,
c’est bel et bien une affirmation.
J’ai 25 ans et croyez-moi,
il en a vu mon corps.
Il est passé par toutes les formes,
et lui et moi, on a mis pas
mal d'années à s'accorder.
À 14 ans, je mesurais 1 mètre 70
et je suis passée de 55 kilos à 39 kilos
en quelques semaines.
J'étais devenue anorexique.
Alors imaginez si à 14 ans, on m’avait dit
qu’un jour je serais sur la scène de TEDx
pour vous parler de grossophobie.
J’étais maigre, trop maigre, bien sûr,
et à ce moment-là, les gens me regardaient
avec beaucoup de compassion,
de bienveillance, de pitié même.
Normal, j'étais malade et ma silhouette
était l'élément visible de ma maladie.
Je passais mes journées collées
au radiateur tellement j’avais froid.
Je me sentais seule
et plus grand-chose ne me passionnait.
Je rêvais depuis toute petite
de faire du cinéma,
mais trop faible,
j’étais interdite de casting.
Il fallait à tout prix que je remange
pour survivre
et pour pouvoir réaliser mon rêve.
Alors, j’ai mangé, j’ai bien mangé
et mes kilos perdus sont revenus
et ma joie de vivre avec.
J’ai pu passer mon premier casting
et j’ai décroché mon tout premier rôle
dans un téléfilm.
Ma vocation s’est confirmée.
Je serai actrice.
Mais à 18 ans, j’étais passée
de trop maigre à trop grosse.
C'est le problème.
J’avais ouvert les vannes et mon corps,
trop longtemps privé, s’est vengé.
Il s’est mis à faire des réserves -
on ne sait jamais.
Et puis, un jour, on me propose de passer
le casting pour le film Tamara.
Tamara, une jeune fille ronde et mal
dans sa peau, tout moi.
Je décroche le rôle et je prends même
encore quelques kilos en plus
pour pouvoir interpréter à l’écran
cette jeune fille hors normes.
Mais au moment où j'ai connu le succès,
j'ai aussi eu une grande déconvenue.
J’étais devenue Tamara.
Je vivais les mêmes humiliations qu’elle :
des commentaires désagréables
sur mon physique,
dans la vie et sur les réseaux sociaux.
Un mot que je ne connaissais pas
est entré dans ma vie : grossophobie.
La grossophobie désigne
l’ensemble des comportements
de discrimination et d’oppression
envers les personnes en surpoids,
grosses et obèses,
dans les différents aspects
de la vie quotidienne.
J’ai une petite question pour vous :
qui parmi vous a déjà fait un régime ?
Allez-y, levez la main, pour voir.
C’est fou, ça !
Saviez-vous que plus d’un Français sur
deux déclare avoir déjà fait un régime ?
Et en même temps, ça ne m’étonne pas :
le poids est un vrai sujet de société.
Regardons à quoi ressemble
la femme au physique idéal
selon les médias, le marketing,
la publicité.
Moi, depuis toute petite,
l’image de la femme parfaite
s’appelle Barbie.
Barbie est née en 1959
et elle n’a pas pris une ride.
Et pas un gramme non plus.
Depuis des générations,
toutes les petites filles du monde
l’adorent et rêvent de lui ressembler.
Prenons le concours des Miss.
Si les mensurations des candidates ne sont
officiellement pas prises en compte,
les personnes qui votent, en revanche,
y accordent une très grande importance.
D’ailleurs, la présidente du comité
Miss France, Sylvie Tellier, le regrette
et dit que le public français
n’est peut-être pas prêt à élire
une jeune femme qui fait du 46 ou plus.
Du coup, des concours de beauté réservés
aux femmes rondes ont vu le jour.
Vous trouvez ça normal ?
Dans une France où 30 % de la population
est en surpoids,
ou un Français sur 10 est obèse,
le marché de la minceur est en plein boom.
Ça ne m’étonne pas : regardons le nombre
de pubs TV, Internet, magazines, affiches
qui prônent la minceur.
Ce n’est pas pour nous conseiller
de perdre du poids ; on nous l’ordonne !
«Vous aussi perdre du poids avec ceci.»
«Perdez 15 kilos
en trois semaines avec ça.»
Ou encore : «Faites comme moi
et dites adieu aux kilos superflus
en mangeant ce truc.»
Mais alors, la Palme d’or de la bêtise
revient aux réseaux sociaux,
et plus particulièrement à Tik-Tok,
qui s’adresse essentiellement
aux plus jeunes
et sur lequel on trouve des concours -
des challenges - très dangereux
qui prônent la minceur extrême.
Est-ce que vous connaissez
le challenge de la feuille A4 ?
Non ? Je vous montre.
Vous voyez, chez moi,
ça dépasse... un peu.
Figurez-vous que
ce challenge consiste à maigrir
jusqu’à ce que plus rien
ne dépasse de cette feuille.
Je ne suis même pas sûre de pouvoir
disparaître derrière une feuille A3.
(Rires)
En 2018, on me propose de participer
à l’émission « Danse avec les stars ».
Moi, j'étais super contente.
Jamais je n'aurais imaginé pouvoir
danser un jour sur ce parquet.
J’étais consciente d’être attendue
et pour ne pas me ridiculiser,
je me suis donnée à fond.
Avec mon partenaire danseur, Christophe,
on a terminé premiers
le premier soir de la compétition.
On était trop contents.
Heureusement, ce soir-là,
je n’ai pas regardé mes réseaux sociaux,
dont Twitter, pour n’en citer qu’un,
parce que les commentaires
étaient pitoyables,
à en presque oublier tous les merveilleux
commentaires [reçus].
Et c’est ça, le problème
chez les grossophobes.
En quelques mots,
ils prennent toute la place.
On finit par ne plus voir qu’eux,
ne retenir que cela.
«Attention, elle va péter le parquet !»
«Son danseur n’arrivera
jamais à la soulever,
il va mourir écrasé sous son poids.»
Psychologiquement, ça fait mal.
Quelques mois après, on me propose
de participer à l’émission Fort Boyard,
c’est toute mon enfance.
Évidemment, je dis oui.
Je m’envole à 15 mètres de haut,
je saute dans le vide,
j’ai des mygales dans la main,
je remporte des clés, des indices.
On fait gagner 14 000 € à une association.
Et le soir de la diffusion,
j’étais chez moi avec des amis.
L'émission commence et mon compte
Twitter s'enflamme.
Au début, des messages d’encouragement.
Et puis, très vite, à nouveau,
des messages haineux
uniquement en lien avec mon physique.
Là, ça a été la goutte d’eau.
Ce soir-là, j’ai quitté Twitter,
j’étais déçue, mais surtout très triste.
Ça ne s'arrêtera donc jamais.
Quoi que je fasse, certains ne retiendront
que mon tour de taille
ou ce qui déborde de cette feuille A4.
On nous culpabilise en permanence
et les conséquences de
la grossophobie sont lourdes :
humiliation,
baisse de la confiance en soi,
et ça va même jusqu’à la désocialisation.
Par exemple, à force de me sentir
jugée dans les boutiques de vêtements
ou de ne plus trouver
ma taille, taille 40, 42,
taille moyenne d’une Française
aujourd’hui,
eh bien, j’ai fini par faire
mon shopping sur Internet.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que certaines marques ne veulent pas
être représentées par des femmes rondes.
J’ai aussi fini par commander
des pizzas à la maison,
loin du regard des autres.
J’ai même failli arrêter
d’aller chez le médecin
le jour où il m’a annoncé que mon angine
blanche était due à mon surpoids.
Mais que faut-il faire pour que
cette haine de la différence s’arrête ?
Au fond, c’est quoi la différence ?
Gros, mince, petit, grand, blond,
roux, gay, hétéro, noir.
S’il vous plaît, regardez votre voisin
de droite, allez-y !
Rassurez-moi, vous êtes bien
différents l’un de l’autre ?
Mais alors, au fond,
lequel des deux est normal
si l’autre est différent ?
Vous êtes-vous déjà demandé
si vous étiez grossophobe ?
Je suppose que non.
En plus, c’est un mot assez récent,
on n’a pas encore eu
le temps de se l’approprier.
Et puis, les mots en «phobe »,
c’est vachement à la mode.
Mais croyez-moi, il y a beaucoup
de grossophobes qui s’ignorent.
C’est par exemple le DRH qui,
entre deux candidats équivalents,
va inconsciemment
choisir le plus mince des deux.
C’est la compagnie aérienne qui
va faire payer deux billets d’avion
aux voyageurs obèses.
Ce sont tous les regards suspicieux
sur le gros qui fait du vélo elliptique
à la salle de sport.
Ce sont aussi les castings sans suite
car on ne peut pas être Tamara un jour,
et Pretty Woman le lendemain.
Ce sont aussi tous ceux qui
n’osent pas te dire que tu es gros,
qui préfèrent employer le terme « ronde »,
parce que « gros » en soi,
c’est déjà un gros mot.
On m’a souvent rassurée en me disant
que j’étais belle comme ça,
que mes formes m’allaient bien,
qu’il ne fallait pas
écouter ceux qui critiquent.
On m’a aussi dit qu’il fallait
s’accepter tel que l’on est.
Il y a des bouquins à ce sujet
dans toutes les bonnes librairies.
Des marques en font leur nouveau slogan.
« Ah, mais c’est donc ça, Héloïse !
C’est fastoche en fait :
accepte-toi telle que tu es.
Et puis tout ira bien.
Les autres suivront. »
Mais vous y croyez vraiment, vous ?
Vous êtes-vous retourné dans la rue
devant une personne en surpoids
en vous disant :
«Waouh ! Quel canon de beauté !»
Comment voulez-vous que je m’accepte, moi,
si on continue à établir des règles
de beauté intenables
et que l’on nous programme tous
pour tenter de les respecter ?
J'ai passé de nombreuses années
à faire des régimes.
Et vous voulez une confidence ce soir ?
Eh bien, j’en fais encore un aujourd’hui.
Pourtant, j’aimerais pouvoir dire
à quel point c’est merveilleux
de pouvoir vivre dans une taille 40 ou 42.
Même si aujourd’hui,
mon poids est moins lourd à porter
que le poids des mots
sur certains claviers,
je pense que ce n’est pas
qu’à moi de m’accepter.
Laissons aux soignants la possibilité
de préconiser un régime, parce que oui,
parfois un surpoids peut mettre
la santé en péril.
Mais arrêtons ce diktat de la minceur
à travers, entre autres, ce flot incessant
de publicités culpabilisantes.
Vous dites que je dois
m’accepter comme je suis,
mais alors s’il vous plaît, acceptez-moi
telle que vous n’êtes peut-être pas
et je vous promets de faire le second pas.
(Elle déchire la feuille)
(Applaudissements)